من مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح
مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوط ينضم الينا هشام
الى اي مدى تثقل هذه الارقام من الشهداء
والجرحى كاهله مستشفى الشهداء الاقصى
بالنظر الى كل هذه الاعداد الكبيره التي
سجلت بالفعل هي تثقل كاهله بشكل كبير لا
سما وانه مستشفى صغير امكاناته بسيطه
وتجهيزاته اصلا بسيطه هو ربما يقال عنهم
مستشفى تجاوزا فهو مستوصف كبير
كان في الماضي يحول اغلب الحالات الصعبه
والعمليات الى مستشفيات كبرى كمستشفى
الشفاء في مدينه غزه
وكمستوى المستشفى الاوروبي الان الان بات
كل هذا ملقى على كاهل هذا المستشفى بدون
غرف عمليات كافيه بدون غرف عنايه مكثفه
كافيه بدون وجود لاسره كافيه في هذا
المستشفى بالتالي اعداد الاصابات تزداد
يوما بعد اخر وفي كل مره تحدث فيها مجزره
او قصف اسرائيلي فان الاصابات تصل الى
مستشفى الشهداء الاقصى دفعه واحده وهذا
المستشفى اصلا قسم الاستقبال فيه هو قسم
صغير لا يوجد فيها اسره يتم استقبال
المرضى على الارض والجرحى كذلك وحتى
الشهداء يبقون على الارض لساعات طويله
بدون وجود لثلاجات موتى في هذا المستشفى
تكفي لهذه الاعداد الكبيره منذ بدايه
الحرب الاسرائيليه وهذا المستشفى ينادي
بضروره دعمه بضروره توفير الامكانيات
اللازمه من اجل ابقاءه ليعمل هو يقدم
رعايه صحيه لا ربما يمكن تسميتها بانها
اسعافات اوليه من اجل وقف النزيف لهؤلاء
المرضى ولهؤلاء الجرحى الذين يصلون تباعا
في كل لحظه وفي كل حين لكن لا يوجد ادويه
لا يوجد مستلزمات طبيه لا يوجد
اسره المستشفى مكتظ عن بكره ابيه تحول
الان الى ايضا مركزا للايواء للنازحين
الذين جاؤوا من مدينه غزه ومن شمال القطاع
والان من مخيم البريج ومخيم النصيرات ومن
المناطق الشرقيه لقطاع غزه وكان وصل ايضا
عدد من هؤلاء النازحين من خان يونس
بالتالي هو تحول الى مكان يكتظ فيه الناس
والوحيد الذي يتواجد فيه كهرباء وبالتالي
يتواجد فيه مياه يمكن القول انها صالحه
للشرب وبالتالي العبء الكبير على هذا
المستشفى هو عبء كبير لا يمكن وصفه ولا
يمكن لكل هذه الكلمات ان تقدر هذا العبئ
بالاضافه الى العبئ على تاكيد على هؤلاء
الاطباء الذين جزء كبير منهم
من مدينه غزه ومن اماكن اخرى ونزح الى هذا
المستشفى عائلاتهم باتت مشرده تعيش في
خيام بالاضافه الى الخيام التي نصبت
للنازحين هنا في هذا المستشفى ومع كل موجه
من الرياح موجه من الاجواء الجويه السيئه
فان هذه الخيام تطير من مكانها و ويبقى
الناس في العراء بالتالي المستشفى لم يعد
مستشفى حتى الشارع لم يعد شارع كل الاماكن
في دير البلح على الاقل هي اماكن للنازحين
الذين يهربون من حمم القصف الاسرائيليه في
اماكن مختلفه فيلاحق القصف الاسرائيلي الى
هذه الاماكن مخيم البريج مازال يتعرض الى
قصف عنيف مخيم المغازي مازال يتعرض الى
قصف عنيف من المدفعيه وبالتالي حركه
النزوح مستمره ومتواصله واعداد الاصابات
تصل والعبء على هذا المستشفى يزداد شكرا
جزيلا لك حتى اللحظه من مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى في دير البلح مراسل الجزيره هشام
زقوط